foreign
put this on so much thanks Laura
morning everyone it's great to be here
it's been a great start to the
conference I'm going to hope hope I can
keep it going here so I'm going to talk
about some of my work in this area in
particular around strategic
communication and I'm going to what have
I done
there we go I'm going to focus on a
current working pavement of well it's
not actually a working paper yet for
distribution but it's almost uh it's
work in progress with a PhD student from
Stanford units hey guys
use that one
I have the right clicker all right great
so
even this is a it's a disciplinary
Conference of Economist computer science
and and related fields
to put into context What I've Done uh
what I've been doing with my work I
thought it'd help to just start by sort
of characterizing how economics
approaches uh modeling decision making
under uncertainty the classic
predominant approach in economics is
best put us to simplify simplify
simplify right there's a complex world
there's a lot of variables a lot of
decisions a lot of stuff going on but we
do in economics is we simplify it
simplify it simplify it and then we tell
you exactly what's happening in that
simple environment all right we give you
Optimal Solutions there's none of this
sort of algorithms approaching Optimal
Solutions we give you the Optimal
Solutions and we'll tell you exactly
what happens right and that's great and
I'm an economist I'm a fan of this
approach but that's what we do
right and the point being though that of
course we're throwing out a lot of
information when a lot of throwing out a
lot of important things then when we
model it that way
all right and so when we think about
decision making under uncertainly in a
variety of domains there's no simpler
way of modeling
uncertainly there's no more reduction
you can do to then reduce it down to a
single piece of information a single
unknown and this is essentially it comes
up in many domains but in particular in
the classic one arm bandit model all
right you've got a safe option you've
got a risky arm you just don't know if
the risky arm is good or not
make it an interesting problem we say
well it's difficult to learn whether
it's a good arm or not and then the
question the research question becomes
when do I stop pulling that up if I want
to experiment I know what I'm to pull
I'm going to pull it and I have to
decide when do I stop pulling that up
right but in particular there's no
choice or strategy around which arm you
pull how you're learning across those
arms and so on right now I should say
there are this has been extended there's
multi-arm Bandits we even go up to
denumerable armbanders there's a lot of
Bandits but when they're independent
right the problem still basically recurs
like when do I stop pulling that up
but when we think about practice and
uncertainty and experimental
experimentation in practice there is a
lot about the world that we don't know
it's more than one single piece of
information and that information that we
don't know is correlated
I don't have to go into too much depth
right now saying we've had two papers
two nice papers already this morning
talk to you about correlated information
and learning correlated information but
once we start having multiple
experiments to run and those experiments
are correlated we get more I think
interesting questions like which
experiment should I run what am I
learning from one experiment to the
other
and it's not just you know whether to
pull the arm and how long to pull the
arm for
right so John and Yuri's paper is great
they focus they use the brown in motion
this Continuum of correlated random
variables and they focus on continuous
search right and they get the question
up not only when do you stop when do you
start when do you stop but what the
speed is that you're going to experiment
to learn across These Arms
in some of my work I've done on
experimentation I focus on discrete time
and I allow the experimenters to choose
any action in the real line they want at
any time
or if you're thinking wow that's a big
generalization of what John did well I
usually do my optic search uh when they
can do this and he's
been part of his contribution is being
able to deal with forward-looking agents
to consult that problem
and so what we're interested in is not
just sort of whether you're
experimenting or not but what action
you're choosing what experiment you're
undertaking and how you learn across
those different choices
I really think it's important to drive
home how important this correlation is
to learning in practice so I want to
just give you one example that I've
found very useful to think about and
that's about young people perhaps like
yourselves who are going out and getting
jobs
all right so when you finish college or
maybe when you finish grad school you're
going to go out and get a job in the
real world not the grad school is not a
real job all right we all know it's a
real job but suppose you go outside of
Academia and get a job and suppose you
decide you want to go into finance and
you take a job at Goldman Sachs all
right now that choice itself to go into
Financial is deliberate that was
directed but suppose you work at Goldman
Sachs and you learn that you hate it you
work 100 hours a week your boss is mean
to you and he yells at you constantly
what do you do
you quit
but what do you learn from that
experience what job do you take next
you go down the street to Morgan Stanley
and say oh well I'll try Morgan Stanley
like I pulled this one out of the Hat it
didn't work let me go next door and pull
the next one out of the Hat gold at
Morgan Stanley all right what's going to
happen those jobs are going to be almost
identical and so if you hated having a
boss yell at you and work 100 hours a
week you're going to hate it at Morgan
Stanley as well
so what are you going to do you're going
to do something very different
maybe you did this before grad school
and that's why you're in grad school
right I did that I worked in finance for
a year it wasn't a pleasant experience I
got as far away from that as I possibly
could and I went and did a PhD
right the point is you learn you learn
you not only don't like Goldman Sachs
but you're learning about the other
Alternatives and there are other
Alternatives that are close by like
working at Morgan Stanley and there are
options that are further apart away like
going to grad school becoming a teacher
becoming a farmer all right so the point
is when we're experimenting about almost
anything we're learning across
Alternatives in this way so this
correlation is is super important
and that's what we're trying to model
when we capture when we write down these
models where there's a lot of things we
don't know and there's correlation
across them
it's a very so very good and then John's
nice result about it's not satisfying
all right his idea is you get a good
draw you get the Goldman Sachs suppose
you went to Goldman Sachs and you loved
it at Goldman Sachs what do you do
right in the classic independent Bandit
model you would just sit there and say
I'm above my status buying level I'll
stop right but I think the more natural
thing is to then look around in in
finance for an even better job right if
you like your boss yelling at you go to
a hedge fund they'll yell at you even
more all right you go for 120 hours a
week in an even more extreme boss right
that's what you do you'll if you like
Goldman Sachs you think hey maybe there
are other good jobs around here that are
even better let me search a bit
you gotta go your hedge fund that's
terrible so what do you well you if I
tell you you don't like it as much you
go back to Goldman Sachs all right so
once you've searched a bit around and
you realize no Goldman Sachs was the
peak you go back there and you stay
there right you don't get that with
independent Bandits and so that's what
we get with correlation and that's a
really nice Feature Feature of that
result
foreign
I should mention any nice paper before
it which also added the question of how
you Alec in a different sort of related
but different structure how you allocate
your attention or your research effort
across these different correlated
sources of information that's another As
I understood another dimension to expand
upon these classic questions of just
whether you're experimenting or not
right but how do you allocate your
attention as you experiment
all right so what I'm going to do I'm
going to
stay in the the same line of work as uh
John's paper that uses the Brownian
motion all right but what I'm going to
do uh is focus on a cheap talk model or
a communication model
using uh using this structure
or
very good all right so another problem
we have in economics we study a lot is
that of strategic communication there's
an expert who knows something more than
a decision maker and the decision maker
has to make a decision and so the
question is can that expert
use her information to influence the
receiver's decisions
can you do this is going to be that
their preferences aren't exactly aligned
all right this was I think the fourth
category on the Doris is summer at the
start the Strategic interaction the the
adversarial relationship between the
twin players right so we're going to
have an environment where there's a
decision maker who makes a decision an
expert who has better information and
the question is whether she can use that
information to influence that decision
or not
all right so to just give you a little
bit of formality the classic way of
doing this the classic economics way of
simplifying simplifying simplifying is
to say the expert knows one piece of
information the non-expert doesn't
that's going to be this real valued
variable it's usually Omega I'm going to
call it beta and it's just going to be
in between 0 and 1.
then the game is pretty simple the
expert sends a message to the decision
maker who doesn't know fader and the
decision maker has this bias
and I'll talk about that a little bit
more but basically her preferences are
different the outcome she's trying he is
trying to achieve is different from what
the sender wants to achieve and this B
parameterizes that bias
this very simple game and this very
simple interest informational structure
is the basis of two classic literatures
and economics one is the chick talk
model of Crawford Sobel 40 years ago
this year
and in the cheap talk model
the message is is jig talk the sender
can say anything she's not constrained
by her information so in other words she
can lie as you can tell you whatever she
wants and then the question is can that
cheap talk influence the decision
Maker's action the second literature
from around pretty much the same time is
about verifiable or hard information
where the expert has to with the expert
can't lie she doesn't have to tell you
the whole truth but she has to tell you
something that's not untrue
all right so for example if Theta is
equal to half she could say fader is
somewhere between a quarter and three
quarters you know that's not a lie but
it's not telling you everything
right that's the verifiable information
case the idea is you could go to court
and a judge could just tell you whether
she was lying or not
right so these are two classic
literatures I'm gonna today I'm gonna
talk I've worked on both with this brand
animation structure but today I'm gonna
talk about the cheap thought world
right so that's the classic Model now
I've already made this point in terms of
experimentation that the real world is
more complex there's more things we
don't know than just one piece of
information I think the same applies to
experts right if you think about any
expert in practice they know a lot more
than a layperson does
right for example you go to a doctor
it's not like you go to a doctor to get
medical care and the doctor has this one
single dimensional variable of
information that she knows that you
don't know
I hope they know a lot more than than we
do
right you can think of a mechanic you go
to your car mechanic why do people you
know have a queasy feeling when they go
to a mechanic and get their car fixed
because you think the car mechanic is
telling you BS and ripping you off right
they know a lot more about fixing cars
and what's wrong with your car well then
at least I do
another big application in economics is
the boss and the manager the owner and
the manager in firms and within
organizations within political
institutions and so on all right and I
put this up here to just say you know
we're all
in this bucket as well at least the
economists here we think we know more
than one single piece of information
than than the rest of the world all
right so we we hope we fall into this
yes
all right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try to expand upon this very
classic simple model
in the cheap talk setting and I'm going
to try to enrich the model of expertise
to capture some of this richness and how
am I going to do it well as you saw in
the last talk I'm going to use the
Brownian motion to represent reality
so now the state space isn't this the
state space is going to be at the
realized path of a brown-in motion a
whole path is there
it's fixed at the beginning of the game
and the idea is the expert knows that
the expert knows a Continuum of random
variables I've gone from one to a
Continuum these random variables are
correlated the expert knows these random
variables in the non-expert doesn't and
so the question is how does this affect
the X how does this affect communication
between the expert and the non-expert
and how does it affect the expert's
power in that communication and what I'm
going to try to show you is that these
this expansion of the state space to a
Brownian path right substantively
changes the nature of communication and
it changes sort of the logic of expert
power it provides I'm going to try to
argue a foundation for expert power in
this in this cheap talk setting
all right great
all right so many of you don't know the
cheap talk literature or strategic
communication so let me just tell you
two classic intuitions that come out of
the
the canonical models the Crawford Sobel
model and much of uh work after that
all right so if you read Crawford Sobel
you read The Tick Tock literature two
sort of prominent conclusions come out
of it one is the communication even
though it's cheap talk even though the
sender the expert can lie communication
can be valuable
but as long as their preferences aren't
aligned as long as there's some bias and
the receivers and the decision makers
preferences
communication is going to be inefficient
all right we're going to lose some
information it's not going to be as good
as we could get it's just not going to
be efficient and the other striking
prediction that comes feature that comes
out of these models is that the expert
herself has no leverage has no power
the expected outcome in the canonical
Crawford Sobel model
is with noise because it's inefficient
but it's noise around the receiver
around the decision Maker's ideal
outcome
so the expert has no Leverage
right in fact this implies that if the
expert could give the receiver give the
decision maker her expertise at the
start of the game she would and they'd
both be better off
so to me that's always struck me as a
bit of a weird prediction about experts
and expert power when I think of doctors
and mechanics managers and Economist I
think you have some power because you're
an expert right you have some leverage
some ability to influence the decisions
in your favor
but we don't get that out of the
canonical model
and what I'm going to try to show you is
that when we enrich the the state space
to be the Browning motion I'm going to
restore that prediction I'm going to
find that communication can can be
efficient and it can restore the
expert's power
so that's the preview of results I'm
going to know what I'm doing now I'm
going to study this classic game I'm
going to generalize this the state space
make the expert know many things rather
than one thing and what I'm going to
find is there exists an efficient cheap
talk equilibrium so we don't waste any
information
all right
the equilibrium I'm going to identify as
expert optimal and in fact the expert is
going to get her ideal action in every
equal in for every state
and so consequently the outcome I'm
going to get is not only giving the
expert some power but it's as if the
decision maker has delegated the
decision to the expert
she doesn't have just some power she has
the power to get whatever she wants
right now I have a quote from Max Weber
the famous sociologist who's written a
lot about power and experts in
particular in political institutions so
this is just a quote to say this result
I think I think Accords better with how
we understand experts in practice as I
said you go to a doctor you don't go
there thinking you know you have all the
power when you're talking to a doctor or
a mechanic their expertise allows them
to influence decisions in their favor
but that's what we understand about
expertise that's what weather understood
about it my point is this richer State
space is going to give us that
all right very good so let me sorry
Steve yes sorry
um is there an I I thought it was an old
literature talk which was
multi-dimensional and then and they will
really suspend the multiple senders
no with multiple dimensions on the
states
oh wait we can talk about it's personal
I think he was back to green
okay so so there are no where the state
is yeah
all right
all right so here's the model
I'm not into too much uh formality so if
I'm going to try to like put it in words
and then some notation if anyone gets I
often get this balance wrong if if I
miss notation or something's confusing
let me know I'm happy to clarify all
right so we're going to study the
canonical cheap talk game of Crawford
Sobel we're going to stay as
close to that as possible
and in fact we're going to focus on
what's come to be known as the like
canonical classic example which is the
expert has constant bias B and everybody
has quadratic loss utility
right we don't need these things but it
just makes everything a lot cleaner and
the intuition a lot sharper right so in
particular what maybe let me do this
point first what's going to happen is
the expert's going to learn the state
the Brownian path send a message to the
receiver
the receiver is going to choose an
action which we're going to put in a in
an interval and this is going to be
important 0q
right and this action is going to map
into an outcome and that's what they
care about
so they can control their action they
care about outcomes the experts ideal
that the decision Maker's ideal outcome
is zero he wants an outcome as close to
zero as possible and this is the bias
the sender the expert wants to get near
outcome B
right if B was Zero their interest would
be aligned and there'd be no tension
here you could just share your
information and everyone would be would
be happy
so this is the bias that's creating this
tension all right so what's the
expertise so as I said I'm going to
model it as the realized path of the
Browning motion drift new variant Sigma
Square these things are known everybody
knows how the world is generated they
know it's generated as a Brownian path
the expert knows the whole path the
whole realization the non-expert the
decision maker knows the drift the
variance and she's we're just going to
assume she knows he knows a starting
point a status quo point so the outcome
of action zero right we can relax that
too but it makes it cleaner to do this
it just makes it easier to see
so this is a Brownian path you'll know
what these look like very complicated
complicated Jagged sort of sort of
functions okay we can contrast that to
what the canonical model the Crawford
Sobel model is so their model in this
setting is equivalent to a mapping that
is the state of the world minus the
action
their model is equivalent I'm going to
give you a picture in a minute two you
know the in the expert knowing The
Intercept of a linear function of slope
one negative one in this case and the
non-expert not knowing it
so we fit exactly in their world all
we're doing is instead of using this
function we're going to use the Browning
part
so let me give you a picture so here's
the model in pictures I'm a big fan of
pictures so I like to do everything in
pictures this is my environment this is
the classic environment right so in the
classic Crawford's oval environment we
know the true mapping is a straight line
of slope one
we just don't know the intercept we
don't know this data so we don't know if
it's up here if we don't know if it's
down there all right if the state is
between
zero one we know it's in some band or
whatever the state is in but we we don't
know which straight line we're on
foreign
starting point but then the true path is
a Browning function right and what I
have drawn here is the red dashed line
that's the drift I'm going to have
non-zero drifts
in this case negative drift all right so
the players the non-expert knows given
this outcome if she if he chooses an
action further to the right the expected
outcome is following this drift line
and so if he wants to get to outcome
zero he's going to move to the right
he's going to get a better outcome in
expectation
but the variance is increasing as the
action moves away from this status quo
known point
this is going to be the essence of the
decision makers model
you know there's one point he knows
where to go which action to choose to
move the outcome towards his ideal point
but in expectation
and the further he moves from the point
that's known the more variance there is
so very good so they're the two my model
contrasted to the canonical model right
and this picture allows us to see pretty
simply what's
what happens in the canonical model and
why my model is going to be different
right so suppose the expert
was to reveal an action
for some reason I'm going to call it m
star like she says do M Star she says do
M start and so suppose in equilibrium or
whatever we know that's going to produce
our company
you can do that with my brownie in
motion as well suppose it happens
now what happens in the canonical model
well now in the canonical model instead
of my own I had uncertainty over which
line I'm on once I know one point in the
mapping and it's a line of slope
negative one I know exactly what mapping
I'm on
and so this is the key phrase the
expertise in the classic Model is
invertible as soon as I tell you one
thing about that mapping you know the
whole mapping
all right if that seems weird to you it
seems weird to me and that's why that's
why I'm working on the on these models
right so in other words this is a
mechanic doctor telling you here's some
treatment you should have it's it's good
for you but it's no it's it's more care
than you may want
that's my bias the doctor always wants
more care than the patient wants right
but from that you can invert the
doctor's expertise such that you know
exactly what line you're on and in
particular you can then say thanks for
that recommendation I'm going to do a
star because that gives me my ideal
outcome
so this is the poor problem in prophets
Prophet saw Bill because the expert
doesn't know much
it's very difficult for her to use her
information in a recommendation but also
keep it private at the same time
because if you give it all to the res
the decision maker the decision maker
gets what he wants so to sort of one way
of putting it is to have influence as an
expert you've got to share some
information but not all of it
and so the point is if I give if I share
all of the information about one action
you have all of it and I have no
Leverage
many of the Crawford Sobel results I
mean this is a fantastic result is to
say given that invertibility
can we still communicate strategically
and the answer is perhaps surprisingly
yes
all right and what they show is you have
to instead of you have to chop up the
mess the action the action space in
equilibrium so instead of having all
actions on the equilibrium path we
reduce it to two three four or some
finite number and we cluster our
messages
and we can still get efficient
communication as long as the bias is not
too big and that's a beautiful result
but when we do that we're communicating
inefficiently
right because we're adding noise to our
message so that's the inefficiency in
the classic Crawford cycle result
all right so what happens in my model
well
now I tell you a point
yes so it's just conjecturing suppose I
call your message am and and you know
you're the decision maker you know this
produces outcome B you want outcome zero
but you know a point that's a b
because this is a Brownian path you
learn something about this path you know
it passes through this point and that
changes your beliefs but it doesn't
teach you everything about the past
expertise is now partially invertible
I'm teaching you something I'm teaching
you one absolute point
that changes your beliefs about all of
these values because now you have a
bridge between those two points now the
drift line is my green line that comes
from that point
but I'm not telling you everything
so I'm using my information to give to
you but I'm not giving you everything
I think that's a pretty basic sort of
intuition and it's one that the Brownian
motion representation really conveys
very nicely I think
all right so very good
all right so now I'm going to say well
you know can what happens here can I
support equilibria and what's going on
all right
so
let's take this model
before I can tell you the equilibrium
result I need to tell you what does the
decision maker do without an expert and
that just because that's the background
action in this model you're wanting me
to communicate with you but if I don't
give you the information you have to
make a decision on your own all right
and so this is sort of the background
context to expert advice
so this slide is is a little busy but
what I want to convey so suppose there's
no expert
we talked before about
if this is the known Point As you move
to the right you're getting a better
outcoming expectation that you're adding
noise adding variance all right so you
traded classic economics you're trading
off risk and return
because I'm going to assume quadratic
utility this comes at this trade-off
comes out super cleanly which is if you
start at some point here you choose the
action
that has expected outcome Alpha where
Alpha is the ratio of the variance over
the drift times a half
so this ratio comes up a lot in this
paper and my other papers right so
basically the risk is worth the extra
return until you hit this level and then
it's not so that's what you choose
so if you if the status quo point is
beyond Alpha your optimal experiment on
your own is some a A or sorry actually I
call it a to the N zero
no expert that has expected outcome
Alpha
if the status quo outcome starts lower
than Alpha
then your optimal action is to do
nothing and just keep the status quo
well I shouldn't say do nothing is to
just choose the status quo for not
experiment to not undertake any risk so
basically this Alpha is the key
threshold
with quadratic utility in this world
it's where the risk return trade-off
transitions
all right so if there's no expert the
decision maker chooses an A and zero
where
if the status quo is beyond Alpha he
choose he chooses the action that gives
expected outcome of Alpha and if it's
less than or equal to Alpha he just
stays at the status quo
so that's the risk return trade-off for
the question of the picture so I don't
know
the starting points of the brownians are
different yes I thought you were
beginning
so this is just two different examples
yeah so this is supposed it started here
and this is the same old suppose it
started and I'm going to parameterize
the starting point
so so decision maker knows the mean at
variance and don't know the path right
and an expert expert knows everything
and in this picture still the decision
maker don't know the path yes the
decision maker also knows the starting
point yeah but it does yeah so it
doesn't know the path so
I should probably get rid of the path
and just say you know your decision
problem is
choose an action that is expected
outcome on this crime and good variance
increase as well
so that's what you do the decision maker
does without an expert okay so now let
me tell you what happens when there is
an expert and can we have expert advice
all right and so now I'm just going to
deal with this case where the status quo
point is beyond Alpha
and I'm going to study a strategy
that we call a first point strategy so
the sender uses a first point strategy
means she recommends the first action
that gives her her best outcome
so she looks at the whole path
she finds the actions that are the best
for her
and she recommends the first one and by
the first one I mean the one closest to
zero
so when the path is the whole real line
that is almost surely outcome B
because there's a brown in motion with
negative drift it's it's gone across B
at some point with probability one
so now the question about equilibrium is
if that's the recommendation will the
receiver will the decision maker accept
that recommendation
very good so this is a depiction the
receiver the decision maker knew the red
line the experts now come along and said
here's my message where my message is
the recommendation you should do this
action
it's cheap talk there's no verifiability
but in equilibrium the decision maker
infers that this is producing outcome B
now she has now she's learned he's
learned something more about the mapping
he now knows two points question is does
he accept this recommendation
more bias less than Alpha that's what
he's going to do
all right so
why is that the optimal thing well he
knows that he doesn't want to choose any
actions to the left
because the two things he's learned
about the mapping are well he's going
through that one it starts here two it
passes through this point and the third
thing he knows is this is the first
point that this path crosses B
because remember my strategy is the
first point that gives the optimum all
right so her beliefs between these two
values is not a bridge it's not a
classic Bridge it's a distorted up
Bridge because he knows it does Crosby
right I don't even need to tell you what
that distribution is because clearly
this is better than any of those actions
all right so now the interesting thing
is what is he why does he not move
somewhere to the right right and I hope
what you're realizing is well that's why
I had B less than Alpha
because if B is less than Alpha
I go back to my non-expert decision
making without an expert
and I knew that if
the point I knew was less than Alpha
the risk return trade-off isn't worth it
and I just stay where I am
and so this first point strategy is in
equilibrium for small buyers
the expert recommends an action that
Maps into outcome B her ideal point and
the receiver implements it
so we get two properties from that one
it's efficient we're not wasting any
information here
right I should probably be careful about
my efficient definition but there's no
noise in the messages
right and two the expert has leverage
the expert is now getting an outcome
closer to her ideal Point than the
receivers receivers optimal
very good
great all right so that result I
actually have in a paper from over a
decade ago and it's taken me that long
to figure out what to say next about
larger buyers
so that's what the for the paper in
progress is going to tell you
very good
all right I think this is just a picture
of yeah this is just a picture of what I
was talking about
all right I've already said that so
let's go to larger bias and in fact what
I mean is intermediate bias let the bias
be somewhere between Alpha and the
status quo outcome I'll tell you about
beyond the status quo outcome later but
let's this is what I want to think about
now
all right what happens now when the
action space and the message space is
the whole positive real line all right
well now we're going to have a problem
because now under the same logic the
sender sends a recommendation I know
it's going to be this point but now B is
above Alpha
and so that's great the receiver the
decision maker says fantastic I now know
a second point but that tells me I
actually want to do some other action
that will produce outcome Alpha and
expectation is that my next picture yes
all right so
the experts shares some of her
information the receiver the decision
maker uses it but choose something else
all right so my first point strategy
falls apart as an equilibrium in this
case
and now you might say well this could
still be optimal but of course it's
cheap talk so if the decision maker
knows the receiver is going to move this
far to the right from the recommendation
now what she does is she recommends
something over here anticipating that
and it all unravels all right I don't
know what the equilibrium what anyway
let me come back
very good all right so how do we support
equilibria well I don't want to call it
a trick but what we noticed was if the
action space is bounded
I can support this first point strategy
as an equilibrium
so the I didn't say the problem the fact
that the action space was the entire
positive real line all right was
important
so let me bound it to some interval 0q
does this matter my answer is going to
be yes and the reason why it's going to
matter is if I bound the action space
there is now property positive
probability that the Brownian path
doesn't actually hit me
when the was the whole real line I
emphasized with probability one it hits
B if I've got a bounded interval that's
no longer true and this is going to be
enough for me to support efficiency talk
equilibria
all right so what happens when I bound B
I got to like five times
very good
so what happens now well now if the
expert recommends action M Star all
right there's two possible events
that are happening right the first one
is and the receiver the decision maker
doesn't know which one he is in one
possibility is that the path does hit B
all right and that if he follows that
outcome recommendation him start it's
going to get outcome B the other
possibility is the mapping looks oops
something like this where it doesn't
actually get to be
we're going to call this event a in
event B
and so now because the decision maker
doesn't know which event he is in
right this is going to affect these
incentives to accept the recommendation
why because if we're in this event
he doesn't want to follow the
recommendation because I'm thinking of B
above Alpha he would move to the right
but in this event he does want to follow
the recommendation because this is the
best outcome for the expert it's above B
that's also his best outcome
and basically what we have to do is a
lot of work to prove that
in some circumstances this event is
going to dominate the first event and so
it's going to be optimal for the
receiver for the decision maker to
follow the recommendation
I'm not going to get into any of the
formula but we have to do two things we
have to characterize the beliefs of the
decision maker given these two events
all right and in event a it's the first
hitting time of a Brownian motion what's
the probability that the the the first
hitting time of the brown air motion at
the is M Star
and in the second event it's what's the
probability that the minimum of the
Brownian motion is at M star and also
it's the last minimum in the sense that
the path must go up afterwards
all right so we've got a bunch of
densities about hitting probabilities
and various things we've got to put them
all together all right and be able to
compare the probability of event A and B
what we also have to do is say given
those beliefs it's not optimal for the
decision maker to deviate
and in fact just this week we're able to
characterize exactly the distribution of
outcomes given these two events and so
we can characterize exactly the the
expected utility of the receiver of the
decision maker in equilibrium
yes
[Music]
it absolutely is going to depend upon us
so I'll give you it's gonna we're gonna
do it in terms of Q the size of the
integral but it absolutely is
foreign
so so the way I put it is
that
the Crawford Circle interests are
opposed and they show how you can get
aligned interest by partitioning the
message backs right it's I think it's
pretty simple but what we're showing is
how the possibility of aligned interest
can come from the environment as well
you know and so this is a natural I
think way of showing where that
alignment comes from if that doesn't
agree I just think that like so the
whole yeah you're right the whole
literature is about chick talk just
doesn't work if there isn't some
alignment of Interest
and they get it by partitioning the
action the message base and that's
what's surprising and beautiful about it
in some ways we're going very simply
we're just saying the environment can
naturally generate this alignment
and so I'm going to run on top of my
main result is going to be for all bias
uh up until Sigma zero the status PSI
zero at the start of the status quo
point there exists a cube up above such
that a first point equilibrium exists
right and in fact it's going to exist
for all Q less than that
so if if this bias is less than Alpha Q
upper bar can be infinite it can be the
whole real line but once it goes beyond
Alpha I've got to stop the interval at
some point and it's actually Contracting
as the bias is getting bigger and bigger
all right and so I could parameterize
Alpha and sigma squared instead I'm just
doing it through the size of the action
space
yes
talking very viable or giving like since
now we
touch that
always
I will tell you
right or like I I there is one message
that now
I can
think
so
there's no verifiable information to
queue I'm thinking if there's an
exogenous parameter
we're going to get into that with a
delegation but I won't have time to get
into it today but yeah it's just a
feature of the model
and and I'm not quite sure where you're
coming from it it's like it's good
ingredients I understand that there's no
verifiability but I was trying to think
of this if it relates more to what
happens with life
but I will emphasize so with the brain
emotion we get perfectly aligned
interested this result is not special to
the brown emotion all right and it can
work with a whole
many different classes of functions here
what we really need is this response
what we call response uncertainty but we
need the receiver to not be sure about
what's going to happen when he responds
if he overrides the recommendation
and so in fact we can do this with the
beauty of the brown emotion is we can do
that with continuous function so when
it's a continuous function it has to go
up for that to arise well we provide
examples in the paper where the function
could be discontinuous and it jumps down
all right and the same sort of logic
happens I'm worried that if I move to
the right there's a chance I'll jump way
down and pass my ideal point
and it doesn't have to be that interests
are perfectly aligned as well we'll give
examples where the expert can send a
message such that their interests are
never aligned but the receiver's
response uncertainty is so great
that he's he's found to accept that
recommendation if I can talk about that
more at lunch all right so the brain
emotion I think is very elegant way of
capturing this and it does it with A
continuous function right but the logic
is not dependent upon it
all right I'm going to run out of time
so I want to
not do that
and just sort of wrap up
uh talking about
this model in this approach right so I
made the point at the beginning that I
think this richer
information structure is relevant to
many domains in economics so I've worked
on experimentation and search and John
has two beautiful papers so far that I
know of in this domain
I'm now talking about strategic
communication uh which I think is
another important domain and what I
think sort of comes out to me when I
talk about it this way is that there's
interesting Dynamics and interaction
between these two areas so if I don't
listen to an expert I have to experiment
right and so in many respects my choice
about experimentation and experts are
this one and the same I either listen to
an expert or I experiment
and I think there's a lot of it's going
to be perhaps difficult but opportunity
for interaction across that
another area uh I wrote one paper on and
ariata is the master of these days is uh
what we call the attributes problem so
where you care about the whole function
rather than just trying to find one good
action suppose I cared about the whole
function to determine whether a policy
is good or bad
right and what I've been working on as
well lately is integrating this logic
into a model of industrial organization
of firms competing against each other
and so this experimentation can also be
thought of as a model of innovation firm
searching for good products or
technological breakthroughs and they
have to do that while they're competing
with other firms
all right so that's another application
I have been thinking about this there's
probably many more if you have any ideas
or questions or thought feel free to
email me and there's my website and I
have a bit of a write-up there you're on
that page you'll see a link to a bit of
a write-up of these different domains or
applications that I've worked on and
other people are working on if you want
to get up to speed
good let me stop
[Applause]
um so uh you painted this very clear
picture of with one parameter uh the
decision maker has all the power to
continue many parameters uh expert has
all the power uh this prompts the
question what about in the middle if you
have like do you have any idea function
classes
no so I can do my expert has all the
power for different classes of functions
like at the moment of categorizing them
into a typology with different
things you need what I have no idea
about still is one at equilibrium
between those two cases where they
profits over the receiver has all the
power and my equilibrium where the
expert has all the power what makes my
case easier is I don't have to worry
about the incentive compatibility
constraint for the expert because she
just gets what she wants and so that's
that's the easy thing if I'm somewhere
in between I could conjecture to you for
a couple of hours but I really
I really don't know what that looks like
I mean the my Holy Grail in this is some
beautiful Continuum of equilibria that
goes from this one to corporate sober
thank you
sorry this is a very uh very question I
don't know a ton about these proper
syllable models but like if I was going
to take a learning perspective
on this
um so I could think of this as like a
repeated jam and there's a word
like you could write down what the
equilibrium
if right like I know basic program is if
I know the utility functions
but I don't necessarily need to
characterize it to learn
the equilibrium characterize the
equilibrium to learn the equation
you can write it down you just may not
be able to compute it
like so like I guess my question is like
has anybody thought about that so A is
my question reasonable like am I am I
saying a true statement and again very
new to this B is it
is it a perspective that people take
where it's like you know there's so many
equilibrium out there I don't know what
it is but what I'd really like to do is
play a game
um and that's where the learning comes
in I'm just saying this as a bandit
person I don't need to know what your
equilibrium is to try to find it it
could help me to know what it is to find
it if I could still try to learn it
but
yeah lots of interesting things there
but I don't quite know what answer they
give you learning equilibria is a whole
separate field in economic theory so two
players perhaps a coordination game
we're going to play and we're going to
try to learn that equilibrium uh that's
a whole separate equilibrium that whole
separate area
if we did this dynamically I think
that's another feature that stood out of
to me about Crawford sobelt if we did
that dynamically it would be boring
because in the first period
like if you didn't listen to me you
would just choose a point then as soon
as you chose a point you would know the
whole function if you saw the outcome
without noise
in my model that's not true and so I
think that's another thought I've had my
model opens up some interesting Dynamics
and it opens up this interesting
combination of experimentation and
um uh and cheap talk like so maybe in
the first period the structure is such
that we can't communicate so you have to
choose a point on your own but once you
learn a point then we're in a world
where we can communicate
and I'll give you examples where that
happens but I just haven't solved
anything
thank you
you got a Time Laura
one more quick one yeah
[Music]
all the information even including the
future I mean there's no future I can't
you don't know about the Future
model and so this often it gets
confusing when I talk to people the more
people know about the brand emotion the
more confused they get because they
always think of it as time there's no
time here the brownie emotion evolves
through the action space and so you're
just choosing actions that produce
outcomes it's just like there's some
function there instead of a quadratic or
linear I'm just saying
nature through a Browning path keep the
status quo draw one in both directions
and that's my world so there's no key
but just action yeah
it's the same in John's model the part
is there you're learning he's got time
but you're learning this type over time
but in a sense the part was already
there
and that's the sort of key
trick or approach is to use it without
time as the independent variable but
have some action space
so much
time thank you